the whole system is unstable and if i
wait long enough they'll jump all the
way from this side over to there
i'm going to be talking about little r
the coefficient of restitution
if i drop this ball from this height it
will bounce up to a smaller height
and again
now
the ratio of the velocity coming away
from the floor
to the velocity just as it goes into the
floor that's called the ratio the
coefficient of restitution has a symbol
r if the coefficient of restitution is
zero people call that a dead cat bounce
and it's something to do with the stock
market so rather than bringing a dead
cat i've got a glove puppet of a cat and
if you drop it down it just doesn't move
off the floor so this has a coefficient
of restitution of zero
do it again the other way up
as the ball comes down
it gathers speed and as it hits the
bottom it squashes down
and then distorts and this distorting of
the ball leads to energy losses in the
ball which will heat it up and then it
bounces up energy is always conserved
but the kinetic energy of the ball is
reduced it's gone from being kinetic
energy of motion into some heat internal
to this or it could bounce and give out
a noise and you radiate sound waves away
well i'm going to do a i'll show you an
experiment in which
this is a container
which has little yellow plastic beads
you can see they've got hole in the
middle of them they're the same i think
they're orange they maybe they are
yellow no they're orange yes you're
right i can't tell colors i'm sort of
strange
and i'll cover them up because i'm going
to shake this up and down quite
violently and they're roughly equal
numbers on both sides this is a loud
speaker a simple loudspeaker and i'll
stick with bluetech
the cell on the top and i'm going to
shake it up and down using signal
generator
and you haven't wired it up
oh george
you've been talking to all the pretty
ladies george
so shall i start go on so i'm going to
turn up the amplitude and it should
start jiggling around and now what's
happening is as you feed and this base
goes up and down you're causing the
particles to jiggle around a bit
and as you
increase the amplitude sometimes they
jiggle higher and higher in the bed they
have more and more kinetic energy and
they can hop over the barrier so let's
do it up to about there and they can hop
over and they do
well you think it would remain the same
seeing particles go from this side to
that side and they're hopping over and
as soon as
they all go over i'm going to turn it oh
cocked it up didn't i went the wrong way
there we've got complete separation it's
so it's amazing they've all gone on one
side it seems totally counterintuitive
you've been throwing them up and down
and suddenly they've organized
themselves on one side
what happened was they started off and
there were slightly less particles on
one side than the other
because there are slightly less
particles over here
the energy that's fed in the base is
constant but the collisions between them
are fewer
whereas on this side there are more
particles and the collisions between
them are greater it's as though you're
in a disco on this side with very few
people dancing on the floor and on that
side they're all packed together bumping
into each other whereas on this side
there's much more space they can move
around each other so these get more
energetic
and start swinging around a bit more and
hop over the top
and so once a few have come over this
side
this is unstable for more one to come
over that side because these start
jiggling around more and more and more
and coming over the other side and so
the whole thing is unstable
and everybody wants to cram in the most
popular disco
all right i'm going to turn it on again
and we've filled it up on both sides
with roughly the same number of
particles and as i increase the
amplitude you can see that the part is
getting more and more agitated and
eventually they will start to get so
agitated that some can run from one side
to jump from one side to the other and
as they do so there are more on the left
on my left this side compared to the
right and as a result there are more
collisions on this side there are more
collisions between these particles which
means that they lose more energy same
amount of energy is coming in from the
base but
there are a few particles over here
fewer collisions so these are getting
much more excited you can see they're
jumping much more and they hop over much
more than on this side
so this side is losing particles all the
time to that side and the more
particles that go over the more compact
this becomes the greater the number of
collisions so it's as though
the whole system is unstable and if i'm
wait long enough they'll jump all the
way from this side over to there
this seems to violate all the laws of
physics because we throw things up and
think we're going to randomize them but
here we're doing it well it's all to do
with the collisions between the
particles being inelastic they lose
energy because the coefficient of
restitution is so much less than one
that it's almost like a dead cat bounce
not quite so they're jumping over and
they all go over to one side because
they're colliding and losing much more
energy on this side because there are so
many more collisions than they were on
that side so the particles on this side
thinned out
they all had high energy they could jump
up and this actually is a filter only
going this way they weren't allowed to
go back so easily once it starts to go
it builds up of course if you start off
with equal numbers in both sides
you have no way of knowing which way
it's going to go but as soon as the
first one jumps it's more likely that
another one will jump that way than that
way of course it could jump back again
but after a while you get so many extra
on this side that it's bound to go that
way and i can't tell you beforehand
without counting out the numbers which
way it will go